all right faith
faith where did you grow up where are
you from um pinellas county florida
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad um i had my mom and
then my stepdad
and then i found out that my
stepdad who i thought was my real dad
wasn't my dad so what age was that
what was that what age was that um about
10 to 12.
how was that to find out that your
dad was not your real dad
um it was kind of stressful
have you ever
met your real father yes i have your
biological father yes
when did that
happen um
shortly after i found out that he that
my stepdad wasn't my dad
so
he was stressful and traumatic kind of
how would you describe your your
childhood
um in general
it was good like the early ages and then
it just got really confusing and
kind of stressful towards like 10 years
old because my mom was like
she wasn't around as much and then
the guy that i thought was my dad raised
me
then come to find out he's not my dad so
it's kind of stressful yeah and probably
confusing too yeah
you finished high school no i did not
how far did you go in school uh
ninth grade
and then what kind of work have you done
like after you after you quit school you
started working i assume um yeah like a
year later i started working for like
gas stations and grocery stores and
stuff like that
and then eventually you found strip
clubs i guess basically yeah
what you started doing that at what age
um
18. like right after i turned 18 i
started dancing
and you've been doing it for how long
about four to five years now how old do
you know
almost 22 22.
now you're pregnant now you're you're
almost ready to
have a baby how many how many weeks how
long are you 37 weeks 37 weeks yeah
this is your first child no it's my
fourth you're four yeah
so you're are you raising all four are
you will you be my mom has than my other
three boys and then
i'm working on getting them back in my
care but right now no she's got them
and the baby to be you you have a father
that's in your life yeah
so the new child will have a father
yes and then
my other three kids
my younger son his dad's involved but
it's kind of
court-ordered
to be involved and then
my two older sons their dad is
far away so i haven't spoke to him in a
couple years
and why did you lose custody of your
kids
um because i was partying and
i went through a phase
of drugs
yeah the drugs will
get you separated from your kids pretty
quickly yeah
are drugs still part of your life now no
they're not
and so
working at a strip club
pregnant as you are i mean do do your
clients
enjoy that or like i mean are they into
that
some of them are and some of them aren't
really no though some of them
they want all your attention and then
like the younger guys kind of just push
you away it's kind of like weird to them
i've never heard of a pregnant stripper
before
yeah
your club i heard has even more than
just you just you right yeah there's
about six girls six to eight girls that
are pregnant right now yeah at your club
yeah but i'm
more further along than anybody else
you're about to drop a baby any day now
yeah
and did you have dreams of doing
something with your life when you were
younger um yeah i wanted to do
cosmetology school you're still young so
you can do it still yeah i'm going to
i think so
and
i wanted to be a nurse
i'm not sure if i'm going to do that but
i'm probably going to do cosmetology
that'd be great
i don't know that
this career is going to be the right one
for
getting your kids back and raising kids
and all that yeah
and looking back at your your young life
i mean
what's your biggest regret
um
probably the men and
like who i surrounded my self around at
a young age
i kind of since my
life
got confusing and messed up when i was
like 10 i kind of just depended on guys
after that and i dated really young i
had my son really young and
probably
i just probably regret
who i surrounded myself around
is birth control ever a part of your
life
um yes but
but no yeah yes but no
but you you have a good relationship
with your three kids yeah
mom's got them yeah
yeah so the circle of people around you
has that changed now you seem are you
more stabilized now yeah i don't really
i keep my circle really small i don't
talk to a lot of people
at all i kind of just stick to me my
kids and my family
and then
i have a couple friends here and there
but
and that's helped a lot
and what emotions do you go through now
living this lifestyle and knowing that
you've got
four kids at such a young age
um it can be stressful and depressing
sometimes also with like my boys being
with my mom and me not always being
there with them but
i'm kind of getting like overcoming that
and making like i'm happier knowing that
i am working to get them back right
so
so you feel like things are looking up
what would i mean looking
at the choices you made i mean do you
have regrets about
you know not staying in school i'm sure
right yeah i regret that
yeah and drugs probably
you see now is a
yeah probably not the best choice as
well yeah not at all you'd be you'd be
at home with your kids right now yeah
what was it what was the best example of
a loving relationship you had
as a young girl your stepfather and mom
were had a good relationship um they did
not really know
they were always they were kind of
fighting a lot and she left him
and me and my sisters
there my sister's
dad that's who raised me
um we all stayed with him
and she kind of left so she would get us
like every two weekends
so it was more like i had him but he
wasn't as loving and affectionate as he
should have been
yeah you're kind of passed around it
seems yeah and your actual your
biological father is
where was he he was in and out of prison
really bad on like hardcore drugs it was
kind of bad he he couldn't stay out of
prison
wow
so
doing this kind of work does it
how does it affect you personally your
self-worth or self-esteem um it makes me
i mean i'm
more confident than when i first started
doing it
but there's also times where it's just
like
i don't really want to be there but i'm
doing it for
the money to support
my kids and to support myself
and the father of your new child is
uh he's working yeah what is what does
he do he's actually a delivery
driver he delivers food
what's the hardest part of this
life that you built for yourself
um
probably me choosing the wrong choices
and losing my kids
are you are you tempted to
have like party on the weekends no not
anymore i was for
quite a few months but last year
right before they got
placed with my mom and that that's kind
of straightened you out
it didn't i mean losing them made me
realize that i needed to straighten
myself up but i think i was just going
through a lot of stress because at the
time
i kind of was a single mom taking care
of them and it was just stressful so
when i worked
i would party and that's where the drugs
came in and i started depending on them
a little bit too much
do you feel like you were loved as a
child
i know i was loved but i necessarily
feel how like a child should feel
i don't think like
the way that i see like my younger
sister like the way that
she gets treated was completely
different from how i got treated
so she gets more love and affection
than i ever did
did you feel betrayed when you found out
your stepdad was not your actual father
kind of yes and i was hurt but i was
also for some reason i was happy
but
just kind of happy to know who he is and
then come to find out he's a terrible
person so
tell me about the the men that come into
this strip club
um what kind of guys do you have coming
in there
they're
during the day they're like older men
and then there's
at night a bunch of younger guys
like drug dealers and
guys in there that try to buy the
females like younger guys
and then
like during the day
just old touching
men older men
touchy meaning they want to take you in
the back room yeah it's yeah they just
get any chance that they can
to try to get you to go to the back with
them
yeah you suppose these guys are married
or have have relationships either
married or
just
kind of retired and living alone
everybody's lonely
yeah
and frustrated it seems
what kind of romantic relationships have
you had in your life you have three
fathers to your kids yeah they were
pretty hard like abusive
kind of and
i chose to
like stay around that because that's
what i was used to they were physically
abusive um
physically and but more mentally abusive
and i didn't i was blinded by it
and you stuck around
how did you break free from
from those relationships
i kind of
i would go and text other guys to try to
get attention from them because i wasn't
feeling the attention that i should have
with
my
children's dad
so
i would kind of
get my mind off of them and start
kinda
like
breaking myself from them
replacing with them replacing yeah
replacing them and then when i did i
would replace one and then
the next one would be
pretty
abusive also
tell me about the transition you made
from working at gas stations and grocery
stores to
the strip club
the money must be very different right
yeah um
a strip club working there i probably
make sometimes i'll make nothing but
sometimes you could come home with five
to eight hundred dollars a day
versus working at a grocery store or gas
station like i wasn't making nothing i
was making
300 every week to every two weeks
so it wasn't it wouldn't support me and
my kids at all
yeah it'd be very hard to survive right
yeah
so
are there a lot of girls at the club
that are just doing this purely for
survival
pretty much yeah trying to raise kids or
make ends meet or support their
older parents or something yeah
do you have friends um
kind of i keep my circle pretty small
though now so i don't have friends that
i go see daily
i kind of just through facebook or
messenger like we'll text each other
sometimes how are you doing but nothing
i don't hang out with anybody anymore
what was your favorite childhood memory
um
i really don't think i have one other
than going out of state once to
south carolina
other than that there's i haven't really
done a lot of stuff as a child
what are you proudest of in your life
um having my kids your kids
yeah
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life hey
um
not to do drugs and to not put my own
feelings first
to pretty much stay
away from like the people that
are trying to influence you
to
do the wrong thing
so
all right faith thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
with your with your new child thank you
thank you very much
you